france pour la tv merci à tous merci
beaucoup
[Musique]
le royaume-uni va-t-il sortir gagnant du
bric site
nous allons rester voisins et amis de
l'union européenne il faisons partie de
l'europe
rien ne va changer cela maintenant
qu'ils sont sortis c'est là que les
choses vont commencer c'est pas un point
final du tout les choses commencent au
contraire plutôt que de finir année aux
clayes livre il est clair que bien qu
lieux souhaite un partenaire très
puissant mieux exporté bien plus vers le
royaume uni comme vous l'avez dit que le
royaume uni vers le haut il faut bien
comprendre que c'est sur la circulation
des biens et sur la production bien si
nous qui sommes perdants c'est les
européens
[Musique]
trente quatre mille manifestants selon
la police 200 mille selon les
organisateurs nouvelle journée de
mobilisation ce samedi contre la
proposition de loi sécurité globale
manifestation pour le droit à
l'information contre les violences
policières pour la liberté de manifester
contre la surveillance de masse près de
80 rassemblement est organisé à un peu
partout en france
[Musique]
le couvre feu est entré en vigueur à 18h
sur l'ensemble dû territoire
métropolitain il en coûtera 135 euros
aux contrevenants les dérogations sont
très limités qui a fait savoir le
premier ministre
objectif du gouvernement contenir la
propagation de l'épidémie
alors que les chiffres des
contaminations restait élevée autour de
20 mille cas détectés chaque jour depuis
le début de l'année le laboratoire
américain pfizer promettent aujourd'hui
que les retards de livraison de ces
vaccins seront limités à une semaine
réponse à l'inquiétude des européens en
pleine campagne de vaccination des
retards qui n'impacteront pas les états
unis où joe biden prévoit à 100 millions
de doses injectées les 100 premiers
jours de son mandat le président élu qui
sont investis mercredi à présenter son
plan pour à immuniser les américains
contre le coc u19
[Musique]
et
bonsoir et bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez sur rt france première
manifestation de ce début d'année ils
sont une nouvelle fois descendus dans la
rue aujourd'hui pour manifester leur
colère contre la proposition de loi
sécurité globale malgré une météo
parfois hostile les opposants se faut
retrouver un peu partout en france pour
ces marches de liberté trente quatre
mille manifestants en france selon la
police 200 mille selon les organisateurs
quelques 80 rassemblements étaient
organisés à l'appel de la coordination
d'associations et syndicats mobilisés
contre ce texte qui restreint notamment
la diffusion d'image des forces de
l'ordre la proposition de loi a déjà été
voté en première lecture à l'assemblée
nationale elle doit maintenant être à
examiner en mars au sénat en cortège de
quelques minutes personnes à défiler en
direction de la place de la bastille
compte rendu de notre reporter david
kelly femmes une manifestation qui s'est
achevée sur les coups de 17 heures ici
place de la bastille et une dispersion
qui s'est opérée dans le calme encadrée
1 par les forces de l'ordre le cortège
s'est élancé vers 14h de la place de
vinyles pour se rendre ici
une manifestation qui s'est déroulée
dans le calme et dans une ambiance
plutôt festive
aucun débordement à signaler une fois de
plus d'idées l'allemand avait amis à
tous les moyens humains et matériels
pour éviter les violences qu'on a pu
voir durant les derniers rassemblements
contre la loi sécurité globale encore
une fois la convergence des forces et
des luttes étaient tous au rendez vous
puisque des gilet jaune et les syndicats
étaient là pour manifester contre ce
projet de loi de sécurité globale en
votant ses lois ils veulent protéger
leur arrière-garde quoi c'est à dire
tout ce qu'ils ont fait qu'elle est
illégale et aujourd'hui veulent
légitimer par des lois donc on est
contre ces lois par exemple mais je te
donnerai juste l'exemple par exemple des
drones toi et moi dans les
manifestations vous avez pu le constater
elle existe depuis un an et demi tout
d'un coup je crois que c'est le conseil
d'état qui leur a interdit l usage
mais en attendant l'utilisation depuis
un an et demi demain s'ils votent cette
loi ça voudra dire que en fin de compte
c'était justifié de l'avoir utilisé dix
utilisent un des lois ils utilisent ils
font des choses qui sont interdites dans
les lois et donc on peut pas le tolérer
donc là ils sont en train de se couvrir
de toutes les les choses qui font qu'ils
sont illégales c'est pour ça alors eux
ils font des choses illégales et après
ils votent des lois non respecter la loi
si vous voulez que les gens prennent en
exemple ces lois justement voilà on est
très content d'avoir mobilisé un nouveau
parce qu'on n'était pas redescendu dans
la rue depuis le 5 décembre où
malheureusement il ya eu à paris en tout
cas le 5 décembre
des échauffourées qui nous ont empêché
de terminer la manifestation donc là on
est très content d'eux d'avoir appelé et
d'avoir une cette mobilisation à paris
au syndicat national des journalistes où
on exige le retrait de ces propositions
de lois qu'il est attentatoire à la
liberté de la presse et plus globalement
qui est aussi une atteinte aux libertés
publiques
les libertés fondamentales dans ce pays
malgré des conditions météorologiques
difficiles la mobilisation était au
rendez vous pour cette manifestation
contre le projet doit sécurité globale
l'objectif est clair et malgré le débat
qui lie à l'assemblée nationale et
devant le conseil d'état
et c'est le retrait pur et simple de ce
projet de loi et nos invités se sont
relayés sur notre antenne pour apporter
leur regard sur cette nouvelle journée
de mobilisation
florilège des réactions je crois que la
mobilisation est réussie parce que vous
l'avez rappelé dans vos titres et où 80
rassemblements dans toute la france dans
un contexte sanitaire compliqué un
couvre-feu à 18h et une météo
capricieuse en région parisienne avec de
la neige
on n'était pas descendue dans la rue
depuis le 5 décembre suite à une fin des
manifestations extrêmement tendu avec
les forces de l'ordre
aujourd'hui on voit qu'il ya des
centaines et des milliers de gens qui
sont redescendu pour exprimer leur refus
total de cette loi pas simplement de
l'article 24 mai d'une loi liberticide
et quelque part ils sont venus exprimer
le désir d'avoir une société apaisée et
non pas contrôlé par un pouvoir
gouvernemental de plus en plus étendues
la proposition de loi sécurité globale
le schéma national du maintien de
l'ordre les trois décret paru le 2
décembre
toutes ces textes c'est toutes ces
dispositions nouveau dans le même chance
c'est à dire un flicage mal chiffre est
généralisée de tous les français il faut
que la police et les autorités se donne
toutes les possibilités de pouvoir
assurer la sécurité de ces
manifestations
et c'est vrai que ben écoutez la la
sécurité globale mise en place par le
dire la commission fauvergue tour au à
l'assemblée nationale est une
à mon avis une réponse idéale qui va
être réformé puisque vous l'avez vu vous
l'avez dit certains articles ont été
retoqués électorale usage des drogues
effectivement mais je pense que tous ses
moyens technologiques qui sont mises en
place matin sont utiles à la sécurité de
notre pays moi j'ai aucun
blême avec l'utilisation des caméras
piétons ou d'une ronde si je sais que
derrière ces caméras on a un policier
content consciencieux respectueux de la
déontologie
or aujourd'hui à chaque fois que la
police y commet un acte que j'irai qui
enfreint le code de déontologie
il est systématiquement au quasi
systématiquement exonérés de ses
responsabilités donc nationalement
aujourd'hui il faut mettre pause avant
de doter la police de nouveaux outils
notamment des outils de surveillance
il faut s'assurer justement que la
police soit garante des libertés
fondamentales et du respect de la
déontologie
ce qui est loin d'être le cas et autres
manifestations ce matin cette fois ci de
la manif pour tous mobilisés contre le
projet de loi bioéthique
le collectif a déployés devant le
ministère de la santé un bébé géant de
10 m plusieurs slogans
ah non à la fabrique de bébés payés par
les français
ici on achète et on vend des enfants
adoptés à l'assemblée nationale en août
le projet de loi bioéthique doit être
débattu au sénat il prévoit notamment
l'ouverture de la pma à toutes les
femmes je vous propose d'écouter la
présidente de la manif pour tout ce que
nous dénonçons tout l'aspect de
marchandisation humaine qu'il y a dans
le projet de loi de bioéthique
bien sûr avec les aspects procréatif
avec la pma son père et la gpa qui est
présente dans le texte mais aussi avec
la volonté de l'exécutif de légaliser la
création d'embryons transgénique
d'embryons chimères animal hommes et la
création de gamme est artificielle on ne
peut pas traiter n'importe comment
l'être humain on ne peut pas porter
atteinte à l'intégrité de l'être humain
même si c'est une question de de
compétition scientifique internationale
et finalement de compétition financière
et puis sur la pma son père et la gpa ya
beaucoup beaucoup d'aspects et
d'intérêts lucratif un couvre-feu
national pour au moins 15 jours il est
entré en vigueur tout à l'heure à 18
heures l'ensemble du territoire est donc
désormais concerner les dérogations sont
limitées le non respect de la mesure
vous coûtera 135 euros et jusqu'à 3750
euros en cas de récidive
l'objectif du gouvernement est la 2
limiter la propagation du coronavirus
alors que les chiffres de contamination
chaque jour reste élevé autour de 20
milliards
loin des 5000 à espérer parmi les autres
annonces du premier ministre jeudi la
reprise des cours pour les étudiants en
présentiel part de migros à partir du 25
janvier reprise salué par les syndicats
qui demandent toutefois des mesures
d'urgence pour les étudiants parfois en
grande détresse
reportage à l'université lyon 1 2 luis
carballo carvalho et grâce d'ailleurs
docteur genre j'en peux plus je suis
épuisée je suis à bout cette phrase de
docteur caroline comble entend chaque
jour dans son bureau médecins sur le
campus de l'université lyon 1
elle est la référente pour les étudiants
en détresse qui ne font qu'une exception
depuis le début de la crise sanitaire
ils viennent actuellement pour des
motifs en lien avec la paire de
motivation des troubles du sommeil une
altération de l'état général avec
parfois des troubles du comportement
alimentaire et une perte d'élan vital
qui peut mener à des idées noires voire
des idées suicidaires
un sombre tableau qui reflète pourtant
la réalité deux tentatives de suicide
d'étudiants ont eu lieu en moins d'une
semaine à lyon confinement déconfinement
angoisse isolement pour laura lehmann
présidente de gaelis qui regroupe une
cinquantaine d'associations étudiantes
la crise sanitaire a fortement accentué
les problèmes des étudiants la précarité
étudiante n'est pas né avec la crise en
revanche on a constaté qu'avec la crise
sanitaire beaucoup d'étudiants ont perdu
leur travail ne pouvait plus faire de
baby sitting par exemple on avait donc
beaucoup d'étudiants qui avaient moins
de revenus pour le premier confinement
pendant 11 semaines on a fait au total
8000 paniers et puis on a recommencé
donc au mois de septembre et au mois de
novembre et depuis on a 1000 paniers par
semaine distribuer aux étudiants une
aide alimentaire mais aussi des conseils
en orientation et en santé mentale ce
dernier volet semble avoir été
totalement occulté depuis le début de la
pandémie
là ça va faire un an que tout le monde
suit ses cours d'art un ordinateur en
distance ya beaucoup d'étudiants qui
sont seuls qui sont isolées qui n'ont
plus forcément de lien avec leur famille
avec leurs proches et en fait ça
s'accumule quand on a enfin l'isolément
de l'anxiété
quand on va décrocher de ses études les
facteurs s'accumulent et oui c'est des
situations des fois drame
tic parce qu'on a besoin face à des
situations de détresse et les étudiantes
besoins en aide pour le docteur caroline
comble la situation des étudiants a été
négligée et ils ont même parfois été
stigmatisée accusés d'avoir contribué à
la propagation du virus en se retrouvant
illégalement pendant le confinement
alors que le gouvernement est en pleine
promotion vaccinale la population
estudiantine n'est pas prioritaire alors
qu'elle serait peut-être la clé de la
solution selon le docteur la politique
vaccinale actuelle pour moi génère un
sentiment de colère ces étudiants en
fonte besoin de revenir sur les campus
si on a peur qu'ils véhiculent le virus
et dissémine pourquoi ne les
vaccinerions nous pas en premier c'est
deux millions d'étudiants
une mesure pas encore envisagée par le
gouvernement en attendant 80
psychologues sont toujours attendus dans
les universités françaises pour les 2,7
millions d'étudiants après les annonces
du gouvernement effectué début décembre
est actuellement à lyon il n'ya par
exemple qu'une seule psychologue pour
trente mille étudiants
le gouvernement français est obligé de
se réorganiser face aux retards de
livraison des vaccins en files or en
europe annonce faite hier par le
laboratoire américain et qui tombe donc
au plus mal en pleine campagne de
vaccination en cause des modifications à
effectuer dans la chaîne de production
de l'usiné belge des modifications qui
selon pfizer nécessiterait des
approbations réglementaires
supplémentaires
face à l'inquiétude des pays européens
le laboratoire s'est voulu rassurant
aujourd'hui il a indiqué avoir mis en
place un plan pour accélérer la
production et revenir au calendrier
initial à de livraisons à l'union
européenne et ce à partir de la semaine
du 25 janvier
en inde le coup d'envoi de la
vaccination était donné ce samedi les 30
millions de personnels soignants et les
plus exposés à la maladie seront les
premiers à recevoir l'injection
les autorités entendent vacciner 300
millions de personnes d'ici au mois de
juillet chez les deux mais ce collier
l'inde sur le pied de guerre pour le
lancement d'une campagne massive de
vaccination
un véritable plan de bataille organisé
depuis des mois le premier ministre
bien aux personnes en a donné le coup
d'envoi ce samedi dans quelques minutes
l'inde lancera la plus grande campagne
de vaccination au monde
je félicite tous les citoyens indiens à
cette occasion vacciner 300 millions de
personnes soit l'équivalent de la
population américaine en six mois
un défi colossal qui a fait l'objet
d'une répétition générale dans le pays
cent cinquante mille personnel soignant
ont ainsi fait et refait les bons gestes
avant le lancement de la campagne
sans oublier des livraisons fictive aux
quatre coins du pays afin que tout soit
prêt pour le jour j
l'ampleur de la distribution des vaccins
et bien sûr énorme
elle est de 600 millions de doses dans
36 région il faut donc prévoir le
transport la logistique de la chaîne du
froid
c'est à dire le stockage les seringue
supplémentaires l'élimination des
déchets biomédicaux et ses 3000 centres
de vaccination 29 1000 points de
stockage des chambres froides et près de
86 milles réfrigérateurs et congélateurs
mobilisés pour la conservation des
vaccins un plan logistique colossal dans
un pays où les infrastructures restent
vétustes surtout dans les régions les
plus reculées
autre frein à cette campagne le
scepticisme d'une partie de la
population de vaccins ont été autorisés
en urgence celui d'astrazeneca ainsi
qu'un vaccin indien le coc vaccine dont
certains experts pointent du doigt le
manque de données et des essais biaisé
mais les autorités de leur côté se
veulent rassurantes
macquart anglais concernant les deux
vaccins qui ont été autorisés en urgence
en inde nous n'avons absolument aucun
doute quant à leur sécurité
autre défi pour le sous continent
combattre l'inégalité d'accès aux
vaccins à la fois physique dans les
régions rurales les plus enclavées et
sociale dans un pays où le système de
castes reste la norme et les différences
culturelles très marqué l'enjeu est de
taille
avec plus de 10 millions de cas pour
plus de cent cinquante mille décès
l'inde est le deuxième pays le plus
touché au monde derrière les etats unis
une campagne de vaccination de masse le
point de vue une frédérique landier
géographe spécialiste de l'inde
contemporaine
je pense que c'est réalisable à
l'échelle pays
le problème est très grande et très
divers il est à craindre certaines
régions particulières et on les systèmes
de soins
actuellement ce sont déjà des fils dans
le passé un peu à côté de ceux de cet
énorme campagne c'est plus un problème
d'accès physique sociale aussi il ya
plein de réticences pour par exemple des
médecins de hautes castes à accueillir
des patients de basses castes et vice
versa c'est un problème de transport
comment comment aller au centre de
vaccination aussi l'état 10 km s'il faut
prendre un autobus
il y aura un coût même si le vaccin est
gratuit
un coût non négligeable pour les
populations les plus pauvres aux états
unis joe biden a dévoilé son plan de
vaccination contre la copie 19 centres
de vaccination de proximité coopération
renforcée entre le pouvoir fédéral les
états plus de campagnes de prévention le
président élu entend accélérer
d'immunisation des américains objectif
100 millions de doses injectées ponts de
cé son premier jour de mandat
foughali - prix poval si nous faisons
vacciner plus de gens alors nous avons
besoin de plus de sites de vaccination
c'est pourquoi nous allons déployer la
totalité des ressources du gouvernement
fédéral pour mettre en place des
milliers de centres de vaccination de
proximité
dès mon premier jour en fonction je
donnerai des instructions à l'agencé
fédérale de gestion des urgences la fema
pourquoi
on sait remettre en place le premier de
ces centres à la fin du premier mois de
notre mandat nous aurons sans centre
soutenus par le gouvernement fédéral
dans tout le pays joe biden qui prêtera
serment mercredi et sous très haute
sécurité
après l assaut du capital par les
partisans de donald trump le 6 janvier
dernier
des milliers de soldats de la garde
nationale sont déjà présents autour du
bâtiment près de 21 mille militaires
seront déployés à terme
autre mesure exceptionnelle l'immense
esplanade au pied du capitole sera
fermée au public
un dispositif impressionnant mais
indispensable selon ses habitants de
washington
je pense que c'est nécessaire compte
tenu de ce qui s'est passé au cours des
deux dernières semaines et à cause des
menaces supposées ici nous devons le
faire et c'est vraiment triste d'en être
arrivé à ce point pour avoir une
passation et un transfert de pouvoir
libres et équitables
c'est une triste situation mais je pense
que c'est nécessaire je pense que c'est
à la fois triste et exaltant je suis
ravi que nous ayons un nouveau président
et que nous commencions sur la voie du
rétablissement
en même temps je suis terrifié que cela
arrive comme ça je vise à washington
depuis huit ans maintenant à trois pâtés
de maisons du capitole
c'est choquant de voir cela car j'avais
l'habitude de faire ma promenade
quotidienne juste devant les marches du
capitole et je me sentais toujours en
sécurité
voir cela est choquant mais c'est
absolument nécessaire et les états unis
qui attire les migrants à la recherche
d'une vie meilleure quelque 6000
honduriens ont pris la direction du pays
une caravane humaine qui se trouve ce
samedi au guatemala après avoir réussi à
forcer un cordon policier à la frontière
de nombreuses familles avec des mineurs
venus à pied du honduras et qu'il voit
en joe biden un symbole d'espoir et
lineage aide
ils veulent vivre leur rêve américain un
rêve auquel des milliers de migrants
croît à nouveau avec l'arrivée mercredi
prochain à la maison blanche de joe
biden la situation de la communauté lgbt
dans le pays ne nous permet pas de
rester
c'est pourquoi nous avons décidé de nous
rendre aux états unis en partie à cause
de la discrimination est en partie parce
que nos droits humains ne sont pas
respectées nous ne pouvons plus vivre
nous ne pouvait plus subvenir aux
besoins de nos familles
il n'y a plus rien à faire pour ce pays
c'est pour ça que nous fuyons vers les
états unis
peut-être que nous pourrons y avoir une
vie meilleure plus de 2000 km à
parcourir à pied pour atteindre les
états unis à condition de passer la
frontière entre le guatemala et le
mexique mexico qui a averti qu'il ne
permettrait pas l'entrée illégale sur
son territoire de caravanes de migrants
des mots qui ne semble pas diminuer la
détermination de ces milliers de
marcheurs hondurien nous ne voulons plus
vivre au honduras
il n'y a plus de travail pas de
possibilités d'emploi
nous partons donc parce que nous ne
voulons plus souffrir des candidats à
l'émigration qui fuient la violence et
la misère au honduras situation aggravée
par les dégâts causés par le passage en
novembre dernier 2 2 aura gants le tout
sur fond de récession économique dû à la
pandémie de coronavirus alors beaucoup
veulent croire que joe biden apportera
de grands changements en matière
d'immigration
aux antipodes de la politique menée par
son prédécesseur donald trump de temps
que c'était l'une de ses promesses de
campagne
le premier jour je vais envoyer au
congrès un projet de loi de réforme de
l'immigration afin de fournir une
feuille de route vers la citoyenneté
pour 11 millions d'immigrants sans
papiers qui contribue tant à ce pays
je promet également d'annuler le décret
de trump sur le bannissement des
musulmans non américains depuis octobre
2018 plus d'une douzaine de caravanes de
migrants ont quitté le honduras des
familles qui n'ont pas pu poser un pied
sur le sol américain
tout se sont heurtés aux milliers de
gardes frontières et militaires position
à la frontière sud avec le mexique en
allemagne la cdu ou fait le choix de la
continuité c'est un proche d'angela
merkel qui vient d'être élu président de
l'union chrétienne démocrate
armin laschet tu ministre président du
land de rhénanie du nord westphalie il
faisait face à deux autres candidats
amine hachette se positionne ainsi revu
de mener le conservateur aux élections
générales en septembre prochain on
écoute ce film il y a beaucoup de gens
qui pensent qu angela merkel est bonne
et compétents vient ensuite la cd ou la
réputation de la chancelière parmi les
gens d'ici et à l'étranger se résumer en
un mot faire confiance photo aw
nous avons maintenant besoin de cette
confiance en tant que parti et cette
confiance n'est pas un don ou un
héritage manif à ce n'est pas quelque
chose que vous pouvez simplement
transmettre rice fatras vous devez
travailler
c'est cette confiance et décryptage de
cette élection à la tête de la accéder
aux avec david capitan spécialiste de
l'allemagne
ancien président de l'université
franco-allemande et c'est le candidat de
la continuité alors c'est un personnage
qui vient de qui a fait sa carrière
politique dans la rhénanie du nord
westphalie qui est le coeur économique
de l'allemagne
il a été
le l'artisan de la victoire de la cd ou
en 2017 lors des dernières élections et
il a réussi à rendre au parti chrétien
démocrate se ce gros landes extrêmement
puissant de l'allemagne si
traditionnellement le président l'a
cédée ou devient le candidat pour les
élections législatives en tout cas la
tête de liste est bien ici les choses
sont plus compliquées cette année car en
effet il ya un autre candidat qui est le
favori dans les sondages et qui est le
président du parti chrétien-démocrate de
bavière car c'est une particularité de
l'allemagne et le parti chrétien
démocrate pour l'ensemble de l'allemagne
sauf pour la bavière la bavière à son
propre parti chrétien démocrate
les deux s'unissent pour l'élection
législative et c'est ensemble qu'ils
doivent décider qui sera le candidat
alors est ce que ce sera le candidat de
l'axé d où qu elles plus gros party où
le bavarois il est possible que soit le
bavarois car en effet d'aidé pour
l'instant extrêmement populaire encore
donc une interrogation avant de savoir
de quelle manière le parti conservateur
se présentera aux prochaines élections
l'ouganda yoweri avoue sevegner
remportant sixième mandat pour diriger
le pays les résultats ont été
officialisés par la commission
électorale
au pouvoir depuis 1986 le président
sortant recueille 58 4% des voix contre
un peu plus de 34% pour son opposant
obiwine ce dernier avait revendiqué la
victoire quelques heures plus tôt
dénonçant une mascarade et les pressions
de la part des militaires françois tu
skavich des partisans de yoweri museveni
font la fête dans les rues de kampala la
capitale
quelques instants plus tôt la commission
électorale annonce la victoire du
président sortant pour un sixième mandat
une victoire sans tricherie selon yu
meriem ou cv ni du hamas je pense que
cela peut s'avérer être l'élection la
plus transparente depuis 1969 de tout
net
il faut ce n'est pas tout car depuis
1962 nous avons eu un problème de gens
voulant triché dans les élections de
chroniques troubles move your gun malte
pour voter c'est le problème chronique
de l'ouganda et le vote multiple
le vote des mineurs la farce des
bulletins de vote ont été le plus gros
problème c'est ce que j'ai combattu
toutes ces années un message à peine
voilé à son adversaire
le chanteur de ragga très populaire
auprès de la jeunesse ougandaise bobby
wine dès le lendemain du scrutin du 14
janvier
ils dénoncent des irrégularités
bulletins déjà rempli dans certains
centres de vote ou encore
dysfonctionnements de machines
biométrique utilisé pour vérifier
l'identité des votants lors d'une
conférence de presse
il dit même avoir peur pour sa vie je
sais que quelles que soient leurs
intentions elles sont dangereuses pour
ma vie c'est pourquoi j'ai pensé qu'il
était important que le monde le sache
des fraudes constatées par certains
observateurs indépendants dans le
travail a été rendu particulièrement
difficile par la coupure d'internet la
veille et le jour du scrutin la mission
n'a pas été en mesure d'observer la
transmission des résultats des bureaux
de vote aux districts et aux centres
nationaux de décompte
nous n'avons pas non plus été en mesure
de transmettre nos informations en temps
réel au sujet du jour du scrutin la
mission craint que ces moyens de
transmission de l'observation de
l'élection d'eads était entravée par la
coupure d'internet le jour de l'élection
une élection qui fait suite aux pires
violences pré électorales dans ce pays
depuis l'élection de mousse et venilia
35 ans en novembre dernier
après une énième arrestation de bobby
wang des émeutes éclatent entre ses
partisans et les forces de sécurité
faisant plus de 50 morts
avec une participation de plus de 57%
le scrutin s'est lui déroulé dans un
calme apparent mais sous la forte
présence de policiers anti émeutes et de
militaires et c'est la fin de cette
édition merci de l'avoir suivi on se
retrouve dans une trentaine de minutes
pour un nouveau journal à tout à l'heure
[Musique]
il n'y a pas une façon plus pauvres de
défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire que notre peuple
c'était une volonté collective vous le
savez pour moi qui dès qu'on dit il n'y
a pas d'alternative on sort du pays
il est clair que tout le monde attend
saft est ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre il est probable
qu'il faille prendre un certain nombre
de mesures un peu autoritaire c'est
intéressant on comprend que vous soyez
déçu livrant l'uniforme c'est quand même
des hommes comment ces mecs-là arrive à
dormir la nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a
vécu quelque chose d'inusité gilet jaune
c'était des valeurs de droite
c'était des gens qui travaillent c'est
les gens qui avaient envie de
transmettre quelque chose à leurs
enfants
[Musique]
le droit